notamment la prolongation du pass
sanitaire jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 vous
voterez ce texte non je voterai compte
s'il n'est pas amendée ce projet de loi
en fait pose deux problèmes un problème
de proportionnalité de mesures qui sont
des mesures lourdes et qui sont des
mesures temporaires ce ceux dont ce que
souligne d'ailleurs lui-même le conseil
scientifique c'est à dire que ces
dispositifs n'ont pas à durer
éternellement dans le temps faute de la
prudence parce qu'on ne sait pas comment
la pandémie va évoluer ce qu'il peut y
avoir une nouvelle vague mais le 31
juillet 2022 c'est beaucoup trop loin et
le deuxième problème c'est un problème
démocratique majeur d'abord parce qu'en
fait ce projet de loi
légifère pour après la fin de la
législature actuelle et le quinquennat
actuel et que j'ai légifère pour la
période électorale et qu'en période
électorale pendant les échéances de 2022
toutes les décisions relatives à la
pandémie doivent être prises dans une
forme de consensus national et donc on
ne peut pas donner un chèque en blanc à
l'exécutif pour faire ce qu'il veut
quand il veut pendant cette période
démocratique extrêmement sensible ça
veut dire pour vous il doit s'arrêter
quand se passe en interne il doit
s'arrêter après midi actuelle tout doit
être sous le contrôle du parlement donc
il n'ya pas de raison pour l'instant de
remettre en cause la date du 31 décembre
2021 qui est dans la loi pour l'instant
et nous avons le temps avant le 31
décembre 2021 d'examiner avec l'avis du
conseil scientifique la situation
sanitaire qui sera celle du mois de
décembre pour prendre si nécessaire des
mesures de prolongation mais aujourd'hui
elles me paraissent totalement prématuré
et elle pose un problème démocratique
[Musique]